um 11 o'clock let's go here we are live
another AMA super pumped to be here I
love this every Thursday 11:00 a.m.
Eastern we're trying next week I'm away
so we're not gonna have it next week but
I'm trying every week to be here for you
either with a guest or just a May
answering your questions welcome
everybody this is your chance you have a
question in the world of
entrepreneurship that you want my advice
on let's do it pop it in happy Thursday
let's bring some energy and vibe up
you're doing something important today
and I want to help if you guys tagged me
in the Q&A it's gonna be a lot easier
for me to see it because I know the
comments and explode let's go first up
Chris Young Chris is always almost
always number one I think this is like a
five chat streak of being number one so
Chris here we go what's up Evan what's
up Chris I want to say I want to keep on
saying thank you for mazing content
feeling the love man question what do
people underestimate with entrepreneurs
what do people underestimate with
entrepreneurs so I'm gonna take that
question as what do people underestimate
about becoming an entrepreneur if I got
that wrong let me know in the chat I
know you're there what do people
underestimate being an entrepreneur I
would just say how much work it is it's
just a lot of work I think people just
quit too soon I think people know what
looks good and they can't do it and they
don't expect to suck and even if they do
expect the suck they don't expect the
suck as badly as they actually do suck
and it it just takes a ton of time I
told the story earlier today on a
different video where I looked at my
youtube channel
four years ago I had a million views in
7000 subscribers and I was so proud of
hitting a million views yeah hit a
million views I've made it I've made it
a million views and seven thousand
subscribers and four years later it's
1.2 million subscribers and hundreds of
millions of views and how did that
happen well it's making a video every
single day and most days now the past
couple years three videos a day just
doing the work every single day
and watch me do it like if you guys want
to join my journey I'm doing on
Instagram right now I have I had six
thousand fans two months ago a month ago
and now we're up to eight thousand fans
or followers just before hopping on here
I had twenty minutes what am i doing I'm
on Instagram doing DMS messaging people
people who-who message me I'm making
video responses to people I'm shouting
at people I'm saying thank you like
squeezing out every single minute of
every day to move forward achieving my
goal and it's just a lot of work and
people underestimate how much work it's
gonna be and so that's why when you look
at the advice that people have
successful people have the number one
piece of device that is most consistent
that comes up so number one rule in the
top ten rules is that you have to love
what you're doing you have to have the
passion because it's so much work that
unless you love actually doing the work
you're gonna quit just because you're
you're a practical and you're saying so
I think you have to find a thing that
you love doing you have to find the
thing that you would do even if you
never made money when I started helping
entrepreneurs I never thought I was
gonna make money cuz entrepreneurs don't
have money when especially when they're
starting up so how am I gonna ever turn
this into a business what I knew I just
had to keep doing it and it turned into
a business you know however many X many
years later I started this company
thirteen years ago
sounds crazy thirteen years I feel so
old I got a whole bunch of LinkedIn
anniversary messages that's such BS by
the way guys don't send happy
anniversary message on LinkedIn as such
spam but it made me look at oh it's my
anniversary and it was thirteen years
ago when a couple days now so it's just
staying with it staying with it staying
with a stayin with it don't don't freak
out if he doesn't work in the first six
or twelve months you have to keep going
you have to keep going you have to keep
going you eventually will find the way
and the winners in every single field
are the ones who just stick it out have
the consistency and keep going every
single day they're often not the most
talented they're often not the smartest
I just found their thing and they kept
at it and they were consistent every day
so good luck Chris I hope that answer
the question if not let me know put in
the comments lots of love and the chat
thank you guys again tag me at Evan
Carmichael
much easier for me to see it let's go to
Nikhil Evan I'm an entrepreneur and I
have to and I have to achieve success
anyhow can you tell me mistakes I can
avoid I think the biggest mistakes to
avoid the way to discover them most
easily are there's two ways why not be
looking an industry-specific
so I would be looking at everybody who
is in your industry who's had success in
trying to model them so the thing that
saved my company was me looking at Bill
Gates
I was selling biotech software there was
no big biotech software company for me
to model so I looked at Microsoft looked
at Bill Gates and his story saved my
company so I've been looking at what
have the best companies in my related
industry you might be in something
totally new but if you jump to a bigger
industry like biotech software to
software in general you can discover a
lot of the pitfalls that those companies
made and you don't have to make all the
same mistakes yourself and so I'd be I
would be consuming as much content as I
could from those people who've had
massive success in the fields that you
want to be in and understand the early
days of what it took them to get to
where they are now not how Bill Gates
makes an extra million dollars now but
like zero to one
what were the what were the challenges
and struggles in that and I think it one
gives you practical strategies and what
you can do but also just as motivating
that serves as inspiration because again
chances are those people started with
less and what you already have now and
if they could do it then you can do it
too at least that always motivates me so
that's industry specific the second part
I'd be looking at is more mindset based
and so I would just try to surround
myself with as many successful people as
possible I do it daily through the book
right like I read a page from the top
ten rows of success every single morning
just to prime myself I want to be around
super successful people daily and then
with the videos that I make I made my
YouTube channels selfishly for myself
that I learned from and then I share it
with you guys and I'm so grateful that
you enjoy it as well and so the more you
are around success minded people the
more you'll start to realize your
limitations if for example here's what I
think is really helpful if you're
watching a lot of successful people and
they keep saying the same thing like
Michael Jordan's sane and Elon Musk is
sane and Steve Jobs is saying it
all these people have accomplished
success Arsene a similar message but you
don't agree with it or you don't quite
understand it how would try to use that
as a as a indicator to say huh maybe I
need to adjust my thinking like maybe
I'm the one that's wrong
like if I'm if I'm always disagreeing
with Oprah and jobs and all these big
names and they're all saying something
then I'm saying something else maybe I'm
the one who's wrong right and that's
where you start to realize your
limitations and your mistakes and so the
more you're around those successful
people however you do it I like it best
through video and through my book but
maybe you like it through podcast maybe
you like it through other books maybe
you like it by going to conferences and
events the more you're around it the
more that success mindset will rub off
on you and Immortal challenge your
thinking of where it's limiting you and
holding you back in life and in your
company so good luck next what do we got
what do we got Pranav Evan I'm a
teenager and I have lots of ideas but
when I look at my resources they are
zero what should I do to execute my plan
1 recognize how awesome it is to be a
teenager with lots of ideas and zero
resources it's not about resources get
that out of your mindset the first thing
you need to do is shift your mindset to
understand it's never about the
resources you have it's always about how
resourceful you are it's very rare that
the sons and daughters of great
entrepreneurs become great entrepreneurs
it's very rare that the people who have
everything lined up for them the best
the best entrepreneur parents the best
education the best connections into
venture capitalists that's handed to
them where they started out for the
resources it's very rare that those
people go on to be successful the people
who win look at any of your idols look
at any of the people who built massive
companies that you look up to the people
who Wayne started with nothing and built
that themselves so you are very
fortunate be grateful for where you are
be so thankful that you have zero
resources because this is amazing this
is your chance to show what you're made
of I would start looking at from all the
ideas that you have what's the one that
combines what you love doing because
there's gonna be a lot of hard work so
you have to love the actual work and
there's a market for it solves
somebody's problem when you can
combine those things that's when you
have a successful business every
successful business is based off of
those two things you're doing something
you love ain't something that serves a
need if you're just doing something you
love you have a hobby if it doesn't help
anybody else you have a hobby if you
love watching football and you're not
contributing back anyhow then you have a
hobby of watching football and that's
great if you're just chasing the market
opportunity but you don't love doing
that work
you're gonna lose because the person who
loves that business is gonna crush you
so it has to be the both so take all
your ideas think about which one you
love the most and which one is actually
gonna help people and go go all-in on
that one
and and start thinking how can I use the
resources that I do have how can I use
my resourceful nough said
even just being 16 is a win like people
want to help young people people want to
bet on young people people want to give
young people a shot and so I would try
to crush that mindset immediately that
you have no resources and therefore you
can't win it's because you have no
resources that you will win it's your
only shot at winning that people have
the resources very rarely if ever win
good luck I'm fired up this is a happy
Thursday I'm good I'm glad to be here
with you guys believe nation I'm gonna
miss you next week I'm hit I'm hitting
the cruise and there's no way cruise
internet is gonna be fast enough to be
able to do a hangout with you guys so
I'm gonna miss you so let's let's make
it count today you got to get enough
energy and answers for two weeks one
nine one nine productions is it okay to
be obsessed with business like I can't
sleep till 7 a.m. because I'm always up
thinking and building and it's all I can
think about it's driving me insane is a
healthy listen I think you have to
determine what healthy is for yourself
I've definitely gone through periods
where I've been so obsessed about an
idea that I just need to keep going I
need to keep driving it through and to
be honest when I'm in that zone I try to
stay there as much as possible if I am
in the zone on something I try to stay
there as long as possible cancel
anything that is blocking that push
aside meetings that I have even on my so
this great example on my last cruise
last year I decided halfway through the
cruise that I was going to finish my
book the top ten rules the
September September early September and
I wanted to have it out by December 6
which was the anniversary date of my
first book I was about halfway through
my book at that point I decided on the
boat I needed to finish my book by the
time I landed back here in Toronto and I
had to do all the work to get it
launched so go through beta good my
cover done good through all the proofing
and editing by December 6 and I told my
wife happy through the cruise I have to
finish my book
and so while Nina was working out I was
working on my book well Nina was
sleeping I was working on my book well
Nina was going to classes I was working
on my book and we still spend time
together we still hit the ports together
we still did a lot of stuff together but
every single spare moment that I had I
was working on my book I don't know how
much I slept on the cruise I slept not
not a huge chunk of time and guess what
I got my book done and you can do that
in sprints both from from a health
perspective as well as a balanced
perspective like if I was sleeping 2
hours a night every single night I would
that would catch up to me you know I
would crash at some point if I was
working so much that I never spend time
with my wife that would catch up to me
on a relationship perspective as well
right or not spending time with Hayden
as a father like I would I would lose
that balance but I don't think you live
every single day balanced I think you
keep making at least for me I make
deposits and withdrawals from these
different bank accounts so I make a ton
of deposits into my into my husband bank
account and then when I need it I can
make the withdrawal you know Nina
recognized the look in my eye she saw
that I need to get this book done and
she was so super supportive because once
she wants me to be happy and fulfilled
and successful what I do but - I done so
much leading up to that for us in our
relationship right and so I think you
need to define what what healthy what
balance looks like for you I'm not
judging how many hours you need to sleep
or how many hours you need to do leisure
activities or be with your girlfriend or
boyfriend or whatever I think you need
to though when you are in the zone
trying to stay there for as long as
possible whether that's an afternoon a
day a week two weeks
it's very rare you're in the zone for a
month straight
you know your your productivity will be
so high in that moment you'll produce so
much gold in that moment that you have
to stay there for as long as physically
possible at least I believe that and and
push everything else out and then
restore those bank accounts with those
other people when you fall out of your
zone and the work that you're doing
that's what I got healing through
inspiration Evan how do we get people to
buy our art masks online very cool so a
couple ideas here one I would start with
you know when you're looking at art it's
so very subjective as to what people
like right you may create somebody
created me this picture on Instagram
this morning she's an artist and she
painted this elephant in this unicorn
and she said this represents it believed
and I wrote back to say well how does
this like what does it mean to you can
you explain this picture and that's a
challenge with a lot of artists you have
a great sense of what you want to create
you may have great artistic talent to
create a mask or create a painting or
create something visual but it doesn't
mean it's going to be easily consumed by
other people and so your job is not just
to create the art but to explain the art
and this is where a lot of artists fall
down this is why a lot of artists can
never really build successful businesses
because people when they look at it they
don't get it and they often take the
approachable you don't get it you know
you suck you're not my audience and they
blame the customer it's not the customer
you did a really bad job explaining what
I'm looking at where if I looked at your
mask and if you understood what your one
word was for example like if you made
believe masks if your one word was
belief and I looked at the mask and yes
it's a beautiful piece of art but it's
meant to represent believing in yourself
and maybe you're even supposed to like
put on the mask or I don't know if you
have rituals around it or even just
walking by the mask if by walking by the
mask I felt more believed because I know
you and I know your story I know what
you've been through and I know what this
piece of art represents then I'm more
likely to connect with it then I'm more
likely to spend more dollars with you
and so one is super clearly identifying
why you're doing this what it's all
about for you what your message is to
the world
what your art is meant to represent and
create and then starting to connect with
people who have a similar message so if
it was believed or entrepreneur related
and somehow you want to talk to me right
I can help spread that message if it's
something else you want to connect with
other people the fastest way to be able
to get your message spread is through
alliances and partnerships find people
who are already selling are working with
your ideal clients and find a way to
work with them and so that's what I
would be now reverse engineering to
figure out who has access to my target
clients what's my message is going to
really connect and resonate with them
and then taking the efforts to reach out
every single day the people who are
related good luck I have a strong place
in my heart for the arts because it's so
badly needed you know art makes people
feel and and people need to feel more
and it you know it it's just frustrating
I think how little information a lot of
artists have on how to actually build
out their business I'm I'm an investor
and now owner of salsa dancing company
where we teach people how to dance salsa
and it's the same thing a lot of dancers
dancers are artists just in a different
form and a lot of them struggled just to
have a meaningful living and they're
beautiful dancers and great instructors
but they can't articulate the message
and so I have a really soft spot in my
heart for artists and I hope that that
advice helped you next what we got
Salima Evan do vlogs videos with your
picture and audio work on YouTube do
vlogs videos with your picture and audio
work on YouTube I'm not fully
understanding that question there's a
lot of the performance that can work on
YouTube YouTube is a very visual medium
though so if you're just doing a picture
and an audio it's not gonna perform as
well I see a lot of people who are doing
podcast and then repurposing their
content and they just show a picture
themselves and then it's an audio track
that plays for half an hour or an hour
or however long your podcast goes for
those are not going to do as well as if
you actually filmed the video if I did
this if I did this whole video look I'll
show you right now if this was the video
no Evan it's just audio qi1a you guys
are gonna tune out I probably lost yours
just in that
part right there and it's not that I'm
you know I'm selling sex appeal here but
people it's a visual medium like people
need to see the content and so if you're
making YouTube videos I would make sure
that is visual that it's not just
pictures if you're doing there's a lot
of ways to win with it like you can have
text with pictures behind it or you can
have b-roll footage showing behind it as
well like you don't need to be the face
of everything but if you're just doing a
single picture in an audio track I don't
think it's gonna do nearly as well
YouTube probably wouldn't be where i
focus I'd be looking at SoundCloud and
some of the audio networks out there and
if you want to take YouTube seriously
then I'm looking at how do I get great
visuals for it as well next tell esh
whatever your confidence is sexy thanks
to lash appreciate it man good to see
here in the live chat
I've known to lash fur for many many
many years
he saved my business a number of times
on some super technical back-end crashes
I remember him coming over to my place
and like my website being down and
staying up late and fixing it so Talaash
is one of the good guys to lash reviewed
I think both both books to lash I'm
pretty sure at least for the second one
but I think for the first one to was
part of my 30 review copies so if you
guys have bought it either the books and
you like them
you can give to lash a big shadow and to
thank you because he helped contribute
to the great content vicious blade Evan
are you a Muslim I am NOT Muslim I don't
know that I really identify with the
religion I was I was raised kind of
Roman Catholic my mother's Italian my
background is Italian you know I haven't
gone to church and forever
and I don't know much about the Muslim
world or most of the religions from the
religious part of things so but I'm not
Muslim dbo Saha how did this thing with
being flattery and a good review just
struggling for more context like what
the real struggle there is for you
I guess flattery would if I'm trying to
distinguish flattery I would say
somebody who's trying to make me feel
good but it's not actually
it's not actually good content it's just
they're just trying to puff me up and
make me feel good
we're a good review would be they
actually care about the content that's
how I guess I would interpret it why
does that matter I would think if I'm
looking at my book as an example so
exactly with the book right all my
videos there's a lot of people who will
just Auto love everything I have some
hardcore fans who just love everything I
make and and I'm so appreciative and
it's amazing and because I put it out
people will some people will just
default consume it and love it
that's a small percentage of the
population then they'll be you know a
good chunk of everybody else who reviews
it and looks at it and those are those
are the people who I you know care about
reaching more of as well to have a
bigger impact and bigger influence and
so what I'm genuine looking for is for
everybody who is giving me a review I'm
also looking for a hey what feedback you
have like how could I make it better we
talked about to lash on this stream who
looked at the book he had a lot of great
things to say about the book and also
underlines and highlights and skip
sections and you know this part isn't
good great like I love I love the
negative feedback probably even more
than a positive feedback I love it when
people have been moved by whatever I'm
creating I don't really need somebody
telling me that's a really great book
for me it's knowing that it had an
impact on them and then I'm always
looking for ways to improve it you know
the top tens any of my video series tell
me how to improve it like if you guys
loved it and moved you that's amazing
that that's the highest form of flattery
telling me that this had an impact on
your life somehow but I'm much more
interested in how can I make it better
how can I improve it whether it's
featuring different people having you
know different graphics in there like
whatever give me feedback I how to
improve it I really thrive on I wouldn't
call it negativity but I thrive on the
on the growth
I hate staying where I am always looking
for ways to make it better and so the
more you guys are on my journey with me
I love being able to get that feedback
to continue to improve understanding
that most things won't work as an
example I'm going to be testing out
different language channels and I'm
trying to
use AI to dub my videos into Spanish as
a first option and then go into
different languages as well the video on
Fridays is like sneak peek for you guys
live because the video is going up
tomorrow talking about it before we
actually announce it and it may fail
like and maybe that may be a total flop
most of the things I do don't work and
then you stumble on a few that do and
going in I love everything I think it's
the greatest idea if I didn't like the
idea I wouldn't be doing it but doesn't
mean it's gonna work and so a lot of
that success ends up coming from the
feedback from you guys I'm saying hey
it's a good start but I think you should
do this or try that and I see if it
resonates and then we adapt it's a story
of every success story like it never
works like you think it will out of the
gate there's always constant tinkering
tweaking changing to make it eventually
work thank you for the love next Panov
how did you get the idea of hashtag BTA
and believe nation so BTA stands for
believer taking action I encourage
people to leave it on a video every day
so you log in you watch a video you put
then hashtag BTA and then your number so
day one would be one you come back and
do it again tomorrow it BBT two next day
bt three if you if you take a break you
take a day off you come back you start
over BT a one the reason for doing that
was I think habits are so super
important for people I think most people
wake up like an accident I think most
people don't have a morning routine that
supports them for success I think most
people are just locked into the current
environment and it does not support them
to achieving great things I think most
people have habits in an environment
that just keeps them safe cushy
comfortable does not challenge them or
pushed him to want to do more and so I
think a great way to be able to break
through it is is to watch video like for
me it's to watch the videos i watch my
videos I get inspired I want to push
through my comfort zone and do more and
so what I wanted to encourage people to
do was to have that as your habit
because a lot of times whatever the
first habit you have that sets up your
day so if you hit snooze as your first
habit then that sets up your day for
usually a string of losses you lose
first you're gonna lose your whole day
if you wake up when you watch a video
you get inspired you're more likely to
do all the other things which is
whatever your your goal is you want to
run you want to meditate you want to
workout you want to hit that first goal
of yours like whatever the thing is you
want to do for the day if your first
goal doesn't work you're likely to not
do anything else and give up on the day
and come back again try to do it
tomorrow or next Monday and that sucks
so I want the first thing that be easy
and I want to support each other so that
was the idea behind BTA hopefully
watching the video is easy hopefully it
inspires you put your hash tag BT with
the number and keep building the street
to set up every single day for success
for you believe nation came from you
guys came from so many community who
said believe nation I like being a part
of belief nation and I really like the
term and so I stuck with it I like
having a group identifier it it means a
lot to me and so that's why I did it
the lot J sending in a super chat $5 I
appreciate it I'm gonna use that for my
coffee this morning and maybe by
somebody else a coffee and you know what
the lot J I'm gonna I'm gonna send you a
special gift for showing your love and
appreciation email free at Evan
Carmichael comm snapshot take a
screenshot of this moment and we'll send
you something in the mail so I should
bonus a price for me thank you for the
love the question was how can I succeed
in the quasi saturated market there is
always room for quality at the top
always there's always always always
always always always always room for
quality at the top the question more is
if you're good enough so you know if
you're at the beginning stages in any
market and it's growing you can have
some success just by being okay if
you're early
but other guys will come in and crush
you if you're not good and I actually
prefer to be the guy coming in crushing
others with quality then trying to be
the first to everything I don't like
being the first I like being second or
third or fourth and just bringing way
more value you look at YouTube
I didn't start early you know my channel
has grown a lot in the past four years
but four years ago is not early in
YouTube days and even if I was starting
off right now I would win by just doing
the same thing that I'm doing and being
consistent
and I would feel comfortable doing that
look at Instagram it's I'm so late to
Instagram right I am so incredibly late
to Instagram i if 8,000 followers on
instagram right that is late I'm looking
at people who have 50,000 followers on
Instagram who are posting way less
frequently than I am way less engage
than I am and and if you compare mine to
them they're there ahead they're better
but I'm gonna I'm gonna crush them I'm
gonna pass them it's just gonna happen
because I will do the same thing that I
applied on YouTube i will post three to
four times a day on instagram i will
engage with everybody on the instagram I
will do that consistently every single
day for the next four years and I'm
gonna win on Instagram because I'm gonna
make better stuff and as I keep creating
more content I'm gonna get better
I created more content and that's gonna
let me win and so if I see a saturated
market I just look for I like it I like
a proven market that I can come in and
just do a better job so it's a different
way of thinking you don't have to be
first I don't think you have to be first
some people win on that market on that
model I very rarely do that I'd much
rather be third fourth fifth and just
provide more values that's what you need
to look at who is in the industry who is
winning and how can you do a better job
than them that's it next up practical
psychology five more dollars thank you
for the love man we'll buy some more
coffee and getting some good coffee love
today check out practical psychology is
YouTube channel
tons of great content did some videos on
my books as well which I really
appreciate it and so he writes in what's
the best book motion strategy you learn
from watching your books so great
question so your one word I did with a
publisher so we did with penguin Random
House they helped reach out to different
PR campaigns and media it actually
honestly wasn't that fantastic they had
me on morning radio shows in Wisconsin
and all these crazy you know weird
traditional media stuff but none of
those really paid off massively well I
think honestly the book publishing world
is still locked into super traditional
forms that are that are quickly
evaporating the the plus is oh they get
you into bookstores and so however many
people still buy a book stores or not
it's still questionable
the biggest the biggest strategy has
been my own audience I think if you are
looking at creating your own product
whether it's a book a t-shirt a shoe a
label like whatever it is you're trying
to make something yourself the biggest
push you're gonna get at the beginning
is gonna be through your own audience
and so if anybody's writing the book I
would highly highly highly urge you to
while you are writing your book also
focus on building your audience so don't
just create a book and then hope that by
the time it's out now you're gonna start
marketing mode no you're starting
marketing mode as soon as you start
writing the book and so for your one
word as an example I documented my
journey so it took me about a year to
write it and every week I would make a
video talking about my journey what I'm
working on the pros and the cons the
wins and the failures answering
questions from the audience and it make
it twenty minute video as I walked to
Whole Foods like I would write my book
at Whole Foods and I would take my video
camera or my phone or my iPad and be on
the street answering questions and
talking about my journey and so as a
channel you know I had at that point I
don't know half a million subscribers or
so and I'm still making videos off my
phone and iPad so you can do it to start
building it up immediately so that when
your book is out you already have a
ready audience to be able to promote - I
think apart from my own audience where
most of the sales have come from I think
also just making connections so you know
on your channel practical psychology you
did some videos talking about the books
that's always great we reached out to
other youtubers and some youtubers
reached out to me I think we had the
most success on YouTube because I'm just
more known on YouTube so it's it's
easier to make introductions and
connections but basically people on
social media reading the book sharing
the content and that helps drive more
sales - and then third I'd say people
like actually reading the book and
liking it like write a good book it's
it's surprisingly helpful to write a
book that people actually enjoy and read
and if they do it they'll tell their
friends and that may not be launch day
numbers but I still get ongoing sales
every single day from people and a lot
of it is from referrals like people
who read the book and are now buying it
as gifts for their friend's birthday
gifts Christmas gifts Mother's Day gifts
all that kind of stuff because they
really enjoyed the book so it's more
long-term or lifetime value more than
just hitting bestseller lists week that
it comes out it's surprising how very
how little time a lot of authors put
into their books just to try to hit a
bestseller list and then they don't care
if it drops off afterwards because
they're just trying to hit the list and
telling their friends and pumping up
support for it where they actually don't
care that much about the content of the
book surprising in a little depressing
next Julianne what is one of the biggest
lessons you've learned thus far in your
journey how has it changed your life I
think the biggest lesson I learned was
regret don't feel regret don't don't
watch you know fear regret not don't
feel regret fear regret live life with
as few regrets as possible I think
whenever I'm faced with a situation
where I want to do something but I'm
afraid of it I'm afraid to go speak at
that event I'm afraid to go meet that
person for coffee I'm afraid to have
somebody on my channels an interview I'm
afraid to write that book whatever the
thing is that I'm afraid to do it's one
I feel the fear because the fear is the
fear is real I don't think it's just
ignore the fear or never have any fear
I'm afraid and what I do is I just make
the future pain so big that it's bigger
than my immediate pain of fear so I
imagine my life for the next 60 years
regretting this one decision like
regretting that I didn't write a book
and knowing that I could have regretting
that I didn't go speak at that event
just because I was afraid and I and I
could have I compiled that and imagined
myself thinking about it every single
day and in telling stories about how I
could have been great but I didn't do it
because I was afraid and how how much
it's gonna really eat at me and then
that pain becomes so big that it forced
me to do something forced me to do the
thing that I actually I'm afraid of in
the moment and I find that that really
serves me well so when you have a pain
you just create a bigger future
potential pain that it forces you to
take action and and as you do that then
your pain threshold starts to increase
so now right in the second book is not
getting on stage somewhere else is not
scary having somebody to come on my
channel is not scary and so like it's a
start you can only do this what you're
comfortable with and then you push out
here and then this is suddenly really
big and then you push out here and you
just continue to grow and everything
inside the circle is not scary anymore
and it allows you to go off and have a
much bigger impact next xeno what would
Evan mean is a verb what about Nina and
Timo evan is a vert would be believed
Nina as a verb would be care tima as a
verb would be probably love or cute cute
I guess is not a verb can you cute
something you could love / lazy he's
somewhere here lying in the Sun sleeping
I like that question I asked it early on
Lily's live chat next pronoun how can a
teenager get an investor if he has an
awesome plan and want to put a dent in
the universe I honestly would not try to
get an investor I think you blow your
brains out trying to get an investor I
think you end up spending too much time
actually going out and getting an
investor versus actually building your
thing and I think even if you've got an
investor they would take so much of your
company that it wouldn't be worth it for
you because you have zero momentum and
all you have is an idea the best thing
you can do they say see teenager
yes the best thing you do to change this
is me list I was 19 I had my first
company my first real company had other
businesses that didn't take off but I
was 19 had my first company the best
thing you can do is start building
momentum start finding a way to to build
a prototype to yet some people are using
it to get some value to get to the point
where somebody's willing to pay you it's
not a lot of money
get one person to pay you to help solve
a problem and bootstrap and be
resourceful and figure out your way
through that because if you go to an
investor and say I need money to expand
this business that we have demand there
is interest in people and the money's
gonna be used to grow that is a way more
attractive opportunity then I have this
idea but I don't know that it's gonna
work and nobody's backed us up and we
have no clients first of all they don't
want to hear from you to be honest like
most investors smart ones don't want to
hear from you if they've done it before
you may get some angel investor who
to take a flyer on you who's a dentist
or something that has no background this
is their first deal you don't want that
investor like you want an investor who's
done this before who can give you advice
who can open up doors and give you
connections and for the most part people
don't want to invest in ideas they want
to invest in potential companies and so
to do that show momentum spend all the
available time you have into trying to
get some actual clients and building a
prototype that you can take then to an
investor to grow Zak what are your
thoughts on ebooks to market your brand
uh I think it depends on where you're at
as a brand I never felt like I needed a
book for my brain there was one of the
fights that I got into a lot with my
agent he's like you need a book you need
a book not an e-book but like a natural
book with a big brand you need one with
penguin Random House or one of the big
companies like I don't need a book dude
I don't need a book to open doors I have
my youtube channel I have my social
media platform like I think I can open
the same doors or bigger doors with that
then I came with just having a book some
people still care about a book but that
that book as your stamp of approval is
rapidly diminishing if you're looking at
ebook it's all I mean anybody can do an
e-book so just that you wrote a book
doesn't really mean a whole lot to most
people there's still maybe some clients
or some people who care about it but
it's not the badge of honor than it used
to be mostly because it's just so easy
to do it anybody can I would write a
book not for the branding I would write
a book because you want to write a book
I think if you're writing an e-book for
a branding exercise it's gonna be a big
waste your time because you want to
write a good book so if you're gonna
spend six to 12 months write in the book
and it's gonna be something you're you
know that's quality then that that time
is not worth it for the brand building
exercise you could be doing way bigger
things to build your brand if you have
content that needs to get out there and
you feel like I felt like for both of
these books the format best fit as a
book I felt like before that I never
wanted to write a book and I have my
youtube videos and anything that I want
to talk about I'll just make a video
about it but for these two topics I felt
like it just
better as a book execution than a video
my next book was gonna be on habits and
I just feel like a habits book is not
gonna be as good as a habits app and so
my next generation would that would be
to actually develop an app I don't think
it works as a video I don't think it
works as well as a book I think I think
a habits works better as a book than
videos but I think an app works better
than books so the right execution would
be to build the app not the book but for
those two it was for the book so I'd
really examine what is it you want to
talk about and is the book the best
execution of it and are you passionate
writing it and if so then do it and if
not then it's not worth it just my
branding perspective uh wictred nil Evan
what was your first product my first
product was I was I was five years old I
drew some pictures with my little sister
and I went door-to-door and I sold them
to my neighbor and I made five cents or
ten cents from there
I sold a whole bunch of garage sale
stuff my family would do garage sales
usually once or twice a season just
selling off stuff in our garage your
extra stuff makes some money and I would
always you know be at the table selling
it I transitioned the baseball cards
when I was starting off in it kind of
eight nine years old it was the 1988
Olympics that I first started getting
into baseball cards and and I I'd end up
selling them at trade shows at the
garage sales I would make more money
than my family would selling all their
furniture and all that stuff and I would
be selling baseball cards but none of
those ever went anywhere none of them
ever took off to be huge things it was
just that I loved it and I learned the
skills of negotiating like I'm
negotiating as a as an 11 year old with
people four times my age over ten cents
for a baseball card right like they
didn't care but that ten cents to me
meant everything when the Michael Jordan
baseball card came out there was the hot
deal upper deck baseball card I still
have I still let me get them I still
have multiple like I said here these are
them I still have these are three that
are on display and I
they'll have more and I remember you
know selling it to a kid at a garage
sale and I sold it for 20 bucks and he
only had 15 I told them we'll go home
and find five more bucks and come back
in five so I was like I cut my teeth I
did my negotiation there and that was
great in terms of building my
entrepreneurial skills but my first
business business was when I was 19 I
had biotech software I joined up with
entrepreneurs that connected with
through University and that was where I
actually you know made some money at
entrepreneurship next super jack came in
from check your trade Mike what's up
question is too long for super chat see
reg chat I don't know what that means Oh
regular chat okay here we go I didn't
know that super chat questions were
limited in how much space you could type
that's interesting seems like a flaw
people are spending money to comment you
feel like they should get more space not
less anyway let's see what you have to
say my business is growing through
content creation blog posts and videos
it will grow quicker with ads my time is
limited if I'm spending time on ads I'm
spending less time on content what to do
I see ads as gasoline if you're if
you're you need to make sure you're
doing something that people resonate
with I do not I have not grown my
YouTube channel through advertising I
have I have yet to see a great model
apart from Tai Lopez on converting paid
ads into subscribers you can pump up
views on a video quite easily but it
doesn't mean that they're going to
subscribe to your channel and so that's
where it becomes really difficult now ty
has his you know in my garage
Lamborghini all that stuff and that that
brought people in and say hey I want to
learn from this guy I want to
Lamborghini in my in my garage too and
so they subscribe to his channel but
because he did so much based on on that
if you look at his videos when he's not
advertising he's not growing his channel
there's that there was a number of
months where he had super low growth
like a hundred subscribers in a month or
negative subscribers lots of days where
his negative subscriber grow
and you can basically tell where he
turned on his ads and where he turned
off and so his views on his videos have
not done historically well if they don't
if he doesn't put ad dollars behind it
and the subscriber count drops off when
he's not supporting it with ads and so
it's a hard model to sustain and and
he's the best that I've seen I haven't
seen anybody else really grow their
subscriber base through advertising and
so maybe you'll be the first to figure
it out if you figure out a model let me
know I'm I'm excited I'd be I'd be open
to testing it myself I have multiple
times I haven't figured it out I think
your best your best bet is unless you
are super passionate about like I love
advertising and I'm gonna be the guy to
figure this out for everybody else I'm
like I'm planting my flag in the grounds
is what I'm gonna be known for then I
would do what what is more
tried-and-true and I would go and just
spend the time on making better content
there's always a tendency this is this
is what I go through every quarter at
least once a quarter thinking what other
marketing strategies can I use to grow
my stuff bigger to grow my channel
bigger what are the marketing strategies
can I use do I do more on Twitter do I
reach out to more influencers or do any
of this stuff and at the end of the day
because it's frustrating this frustrates
ox man it sucks I spent four years to
build something up super frustrating but
at the end of the day is what it always
comes down to make better content if
your content was better Mike it would
spread and that is the honest truth and
so spend more time making better content
when I look back on my channel my
content I thought was still good and it
only hit a certain percentage of people
because they liked it and most people
didn't because I was still in the early
stages of my game even though I had what
I thought were great opinions and great
content and a lot of my opinions haven't
changed since how we deliver them has
changed my on-camera presence has gotten
way better the energy has gone up a lot
our editing on the videos and the
research and the team building that
we've done has helped the video
substantially
you deserve what you have is what I
always end up telling myself I deserve
to have 1.2 million subscribers and I
don't deserve to have 10 and I 10
million subscribers and I don't deserve
to have a hundred thousand subscribers I
deserve what I have for the work that I
put in and for the quality of product
that I've created and if I made better
videos then I would deserve to have 10
million subscribers and for everybody
who comments on my channel is that you
deserve more views and more subscribers
I don't because I'm not making good
enough stuff and so I would apply the
same thing to you before I look at
advertising again unless you just have
an obsession with advertising and you
are gonna be the guy who figures it out
then I would say I deserve to be where
I'm at
my content is not good enough to be a
hundred thousand subscribers yet I'm
gonna spend as much time and effort and
energy as I have into making better
content that resonates with people and
that sucks that's a really tough pill to
swallow that message really hurts but
it's the truth
and when you embrace it that's when
things actually get better and it's what
I tell myself so I eat that same pill
every single day apart from the once a
quarter where I try to think what else
can I be doing why is this so hard right
you fall back into three great videos a
day to keep building your channel thank
you for the super chat next per nav Evan
how do you find how did you find your
passion I found my passion because I got
invited to speak at an event I had sold
my business and this young entrepreneur
success story I got invited to speak at
a local YMCA and just to share my story
and I was expecting a big crowd it was a
free event that was had a lot of
promotion and three people showed up for
it in my heart sunk and I felt like I
wasted my time going in and I just spent
like two weeks preparing for this thing
and promoting it and three people showed
up to this event and I when I opened the
door and saw three people there I felt
like this is never gonna work this was a
stupid idea
what a waste of time but three people
showed up and so I I was gonna help them
right I made the commitment like three
with one person show if I'm doing this
live hangout here and one person shows
up I'm gonna deliver a show for that one
person I'm gonna be as helpful as
possible because I made that commitment
to them
it was awesome I really helped those
three people they left that event you
know different people from when they
came in and it just filled my soul and
and I didn't know how was gonna work out
and I didn't think it would ever work
out right if three people come to a free
thing how will you ever make money from
it just doesn't make sense but I had to
find a way to keep going
even if it didn't make sense and I think
that's where it becomes really difficult
that's the head versus heart decision my
head was saying well this is stupid and
it's never gonna work and my heart
saying I don't care I have to find a way
to keep going and when you find the
thing that you want to go back to and do
again and again and again and again and
the asset test doesn't have to be I want
to do this for the rest of my life
it's going in and saying I want to do
that again that was really cool and then
when you go do it again it's like I
really want to do it again it keeps you
know continues to build when you find
that thing then it may not make sense
practically how are you gonna do it but
you have to keep going and if you stick
on something that you love doing even if
it doesn't make practical sense your
head will figure out a way for it to
make practical sense so the big
decisions you make with the heart small
ones with the head next word we got
Nigel
Evan I just joined the Chicago investors
Association to get patents for designs
is this a good move or should I engage
with an investor I previously had
contact with so if you're looking for an
investor to Faton that is super super
super challenging if you meant inventors
association that may be something
different and investors typically don't
want to be in the R&D stage the only way
that I see it working really is if you
have an investor who really understands
your industry and has connections and
customers in and can say here is what
how I see this thing working out you
don't wanna you don't again to the
question before you don't want an
investor who's just giving you money you
do not want that investor somebody who
even if you dealt with them before who's
just throwing you 10k 20k 50k 100k
whatever you're looking for but they're
not gonna help you build the business
they're not gonna teach you anything
they're not gonna open up doors they're
not gonna be a mentor for you you don't
want
that person because you're stuck with
them forever as long as you have your
business you have this person as an
investor in your company and if you have
a crappy first investor the more serious
investors don't want to join in if
you've given up 20% of your business to
this investor who's not going to help
your company and then you're actually
building something and you go to a VC
they will often back away from buying
into your business because you took the
wrong investment deal because they don't
want to spend money to buy out another
investor the money they spend they want
to put it to use to grow the company and
if you have already been diluted so much
because you've given up chunks to people
who don't who aren't contributing then
they're gonna question your motivation
if you're stuck with 5% of your company
do you still want to work every single
day building this thing up right and so
you have to be really careful but giving
up equity to somebody who is not going
to be a long-term part of your company
so if I'm if I have an invention idea
the best investor would be somebody who
can take that idea and market it where
they are you're the brains and they're
part of the kind of sales marketing arm
for you really open up some doors and
contracts for you and then funding the
patent makes sense the option that we
looked at for my business was partnering
up with our lawyer so go to lawyers who
have a patent business and ideally a
bigger company not just a small patent
lawyer because a lot of times they don't
have contacts but a patent lawyer who is
part of a bigger firm and if that firm
part of what a lawyers strengths is not
just doing the legal work it's helping
their clients through connections right
so what I would try to do is find
whatever industry you're in like if
you're in automotive I try to find a law
firm that has a lot of automotive
clients and then I would work with one
of the patent lawyers for that legal
firm with the hope of them being able to
transition it to introduce it to their
automotive clients and take a piece of
whatever deal so whether they divert a
hundred percent of their fees or a
portion of their fees but they're
gaining the back because they're gonna
earn a commission on making the
introduction or just the fact that
they're making an introduction to a big
client of theirs builds a massive
relationship
in whatever the $5,000 or $10,000 or
whatever it is that they would get from
it is meaningless because they're
billing five million dollars with this
big client that's that's the it's one of
the greatest ways and we were really
close on making that deal with the
lawyer we got bought out before we made
that deal but you need to be if you're
if you're bringing somebody on it needs
to be somebody who's gonna be leverage
for you who open doors will be an asset
and not just dumb money do not take on
dumb money into your business next
Salima evan equipment to start making
videos edit vs. raw footage so listen
when I started I did everything myself
I used a camcorder that we had I used
the DSLR that we had uses little tiny
flip thing that I had I did not spend
any money buying anything I did all the
editing myself with Windows Movie Maker
and then upgraded to Camtasia and then
eventually hired somebody to edit my
videos and that allowed me to ramp up my
production I'm a big believer not
spending money till I'm making money and
being as resourceful as possible
oh the first camera that I bought was
from Costco and again I was making a
little bit of money coming in so and I
already had a successful business right
like I exited my first business I built
a second company with my website I was
making money and I'm starting this new
thing out on the side and I'm
bootstrapping everything from the get I
bought my first camera at Costco 300
bucks and I used that for six months a
year and then I kept upgrading my
cameras at Costco because you could try
it for 30 days and still take it back
for a refund if you weren't getting if
you didn't like it which had the most
generous return policy of any of the
stores at least here in Canada and then
just slowly started expanding like now
I've got a more professional set up I
have a cameraman who comes in once a
month to film my big videos a lot of the
other videos even now I'm filming off of
a Logitech it's a 4k camera I use
another launch at a camera that cost me
99 bucks and I use that for four years
this one is maybe 300 it's still not
that super expensive this microphone is
a lot more expensive that I just got in
the past couple months so it doesn't
have it's never about the gear honestly
it's not about the gear
blaming the gear it's you you suck right
like I suck I suck right I am so pumped
to go on my cruise and film all my
videos where's my phone somewhere I'm
gonna film all my videos off of my phone
and I'm so pumped to do it because it's
not I want to show my camera man like
look boom the same number of views or
higher from me on my camera because the
biggest factor in everything is not the
gear and not the camera man it's me I
need to turn up I need to do better I
could make this video off of my cell
phone and if I'm 10 times better it
won't matter if I'm in a dark room or if
I have a great microphone or not you
have to be able to hear me obviously you
have to be able to see me there's some
minimum thresholds but I still film
videos off of my camera and you can too
and I think too often people get locked
into I need the right gear and I need to
spend thousands of dollars you don't you
already have the gear you have a phone
that's enough you could go live and make
videos you could go on snapchat and
Instagram and do the stories which I'm
doing every single day no editing right
like quick snaps and at the end of the
day it's gonna come down to how good are
you if I had to pick where I'm gonna
spend my dollars my time my investment
it's always gonna be in me first it
always being you first way more you you
you you you you you you you you you you
you
and then 1% gear and people don't like
to hear that because the gear seems like
an easy solution stop focusing on the
gear it's you you suck I suck now let's
get better right let's make amazing
content because as much as we suck we're
also awesome and we have amazing
potential and if you invested the time
and energy to really make yourself great
on camera you general blow up I'm
looking forward to seeing your content I
want to post it for now I really want to
help you with untapped potential how can
I help you
so one of the things I realized with
this mission that I'm on to help solve
the world's biggest problem is I can't
do it alone I need help and I'm open you
know pitch me your ideas at the if you
go to my website I've been comical calm
at the bottom I'd list some of the
things that are the most
immediate needs and I'm working on but
I'm also open to other ideas to see if
there's a fit so it's more on you check
out the site come with some ideas let me
know and maybe we can do something
Felicia how do you consistently say no
to work or opportunities where you the
potential client is super pumped for you
to do the work but it doesn't speak to
your heart just experience just knowing
that this is not gonna work out just
knowing that's gonna be a pain the last
one that I did so I I had this rule for
awhile just just by being burned by
clients and not burn like they screwed
me over it's just it's not worth it
working with with clients who don't
respect what you're doing it's not work
that you love it's just it just grinds
you down and so I had a the last project
I worked on after I said I'd never do it
again I had worked on one more it was
because of sue an agency and an agency
that I had worked with before and I had
a great relationship with and they
brought on a new client this huge credit
card company and they wanted me to do a
deal with them and I said I don't you
know I don't think it's gonna work I
don't think the terms are good I don't I
don't think like they get what I'm
trying to do and I don't think the
contents gonna be really good
I said please do it please try it please
didn't mean a lot to us you know it's a
perfect fit and even though my heart
said no I still said yes because I like
the agency and I figured okay we can try
to find a me to work and I'm just trying
to help them out more than even the
client long story short you know instead
of a multi production deal we did one
video it didn't you know it didn't feel
great it didn't take off
nobody ended up being super happy and
and we just decided not to finish deal
he was like the cleanest thing is you
know what this isn't this is working out
for anybody so let's stop it here and I
and I knew it right like I knew what
going in I knew this was not gonna be a
good fit going in and I tried to do it
to help out you know my friends my
clients the agencies and ever since then
it's been there's been a huge huge huge
huge deals that have come my way that
I've said no to because it's just not
it's not the right fit it's not the
right fit
I will not promote something that I have
not using myself I would not promote
something where somebody is just trying
to pick
something instead of actually offer
value and the brands that have
approached me our giant names and it's
just not I'm saying no and I feel great
about it so I think just the experience
and the pain like the pain is good in
micro and macro it makes you better
quick example one of the things that I'm
trying to remember to do every time is
when I post an Instagram story I put a
hashtag on it you know you put a hashtag
on it and you add it to a highlight I
don't always remember because I'm
posting too you know six different
networks every single day responded to
everybody and I don't I remember the
post but I don't always remember the the
details of putting a hashtag on it and
so I did it yesterday
and Alex on my tds team said well you
can just delete that story and put it up
again with the hashtag like no I'm
putting it up as it is because I want to
feel the pain I want to feel the
suffering and feel how badly I feel that
I posted it without it that for future
ones I'll remember and so I think I
think you learn to get better through
the pains and mistakes that you make and
so it sounds like you've already made
enough of the pains and mistakes and
understand at least for me it's
understanding that it's actually the
best thing that I can do for them by
saying no is better than me producing
work that I'm not really attached to
like everybody will win it looks great
on paper but when you actually get into
details everybody ends up losing by you
doing that project and so having a
foresight to figure that out and staying
true to who you are as an entrepreneur I
think it makes it just so so so much
easier and hopefully you've learned the
lesson but if not then just say say yes
that one more deal without your heart
sawed in two and then feel the pain and
the suffering of the months of agony of
working on that deal and then maybe
you'll remember the next time and if not
take one more until you have learned
your lesson like you touch the hot stove
long enough as many times you realize
that's hot I'm not gonna touch that
anymore that's not good for me
right and you might figure it out the
first time and if not then the second
the third of the fourth but eventually
you get it cuz humans don't walk around
touching hot stoves every day and so
hopefully you've learned your lesson and
if not use the pain to be something good
so that you don't do it again
guys it's been an amazing hour thank you
so much for the love I'm gonna miss you
tremendously next week when I'm on my
cruise and I'm I'm super pumped to come
back and see you in two weeks having a
hangout I think we're back with Stephen
Kelly which I'm excited to do it's been
a while since he's been on the show with
with both it's Thursday we still have
time left it's noon for me East Coast
there's still a good chunk of the day
left I want you to do something today
that that you are proud of like if I've
given you any energy any value in this
session today I want you to pour that
into something amazing meaningful
something that you can hang your hat on
and say look what I did today was a it
was an awesome day regardless of how
crappy a week they might have had up
until this point everything's about to
change you're gonna make something that
you want to show your grandkids today
and I really sincerely hope that you
pour that kind of love and energy into
the remaining hours of today thank you
guys so much the love I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love and I'll see you soon
guys